doesn't it look delicious it's amazing
oh my god who's gonna eat this me
we never look at the past in a nostalgic
way we look at the past in a critical
way to get the best from the past into
the future
taka join me please hear my buddy
taka my brother in my restaurant osteria
franciscana
we are rated the best restaurant in the
world but it's
much more than that it's about feeding
people with emotions
i want to teach you the way to evolve
classic recipes from traditional italian
cuisine
and bring them into the future this is
like the pasta
is talking to you and he's saying eat me
please
eat me i'm here for you how you can
improve
tradition this is panettone in a
traditional way
this is a panettone you can make from
the leftover
can you imagine but this is 100 times
better than this
you know in cooking you always have to
keep the door open for the unexpected
i want to tell you a story at the moment
i had to create pesto for
120 people we are out of pinellas what
we gonna do
bread crumbs we put bread crumbs instead
of pineapples
this is like exactly how to evolve
tradition tradition
in evolution don't throw away anything
you can use everything and make it even
better
ask those ingredients the right question
they're gonna answer
cooking is a natural love and it's
bigger and it's deeper
so you you're gonna explore where you
come from you're gonna explore your
memories
your palate is gonna talk to you and
it's gonna tell you
where to go it's up to you because you
are expressing
yourself your experience your own flavor
i'm gonna show you how to be free
to imagine to dream to transfer
emotion sono massimo butura
e questa el amia master class
[Music]
you